[Music]
foreign
on Sunday and I'd still see them out
from the night before they have Weight
Watchers meetings yeah you have to go to
meetings I didn't know that yeah you
have to go to meetings so it's like an
Alcoholics Anonymous thing yeah you have
to go they weigh you then they talk
about knowledge for an hour how to avoid
this how to avoid that either when you
go on vacation need to toast with the
baked potato you know a little [__] like
that you know eat toast with big potato
I'm just saying you know what the [__]
they just it's like 35 minutes you go in
you pay your dues and you get the [__]
out of there huh some people weigh in
some people don't weigh in
some people go down there just to not
lose weight at all they'll go there
every [__] week just to get out of
the house
it really is an amazing thing you know
but they have them like at 9 11. isn't
that what happens with a lot of people
they get involved with almost anything
like there's a lot of things that people
do where they're just trying to get out
of the house whether it's going bowling
and I remember I went to a Renaissance
Fair once and uh there was you know
everyone in the Renaissance Fair pretty
much everyone talks like they're from
another time right they are Milady you
know dust thou want you know they speak
that way but this one lady wouldn't do
it she was breaking character like she
was just there to hang out and uh she
was complaining about her husband her
husband won't take his medicine I went
to the pharmacy I got him all this
medicine and this other chick was pissed
off that she wouldn't you know go along
with it she goes uh
sorry I don't understand what Dost thou
mean about medication and prescriptions
what are they speaking about like she
was speaking you know she was like
trying to the other bit [__] was like
mad at her like come on cut the [__] I'm
talking about I'm trying to complain
here she was just trying to complain she
just she wasn't into being in a
Renaissance Fair she just wanted to get
the [__] out of the house and [__] and
whine and so she put on some crazy
European outfit and went out to this
renaissance fair and was just trying to
treat it like it was just a normal
coffee shop just hang out and whine
about things my dad does it in Florida
he retired he moved down there he was
bored he does this like Community Patrol
thing in a police car like the sheriff's
office has it he was like four hours a
week they give him a real uniform he
goes around and he had to learn the
codes for things I think he's gonna
shoot a black dude
what's his name Zimmerman that's where
he is oh God it's it's we had this
conversation on your podcast about I
always believed that if you want to do
something you know you just keep showing
up you know and uh I thought about it
after like when I lived in Seattle
Seattle was my real Open Mic era you
know so on Mondays and Tuesdays let's
say 20 people there that's what the list
was 20 people everybody had six minutes
seven minutes the last two guys probably
had 10 minutes
I say out of those 20 people seven of
them were just there to fill a void but
do you goof on them no
that that's what works for them yeah
they have a local job they uh just want
to do comedy as a hobby you know but
that happens and everything yeah I went
to today I said [__] it I was sitting
there and I had nothing going on I said
you know I want to try these knee pads
because when I tried the knee pad first
after the surgery it didn't fit so I put
the knee pad on so I go it fits I put my
gee pants on just go to jiu jitsu and
just just do hip escapes that's it just
make the legs go that way make them go
this way once some get tired I'll get
the [__] out of the dog I was drenched
and it's a big difference between an
elliptical sweat and Jiu Jitsu sweat Jiu
Jitsu sweat you know and you got a line
you know when it's on your neck and [__]
and it's coming out of your head pause
and [__] it's tremendous you're doing no
Gee right no I do when you do a ghee and
you know you're you're working out when
you take that gate and you just [__]
wring it out
when you get that big that big heavy
thick canvas ghee and it just soaked oh
my God today I went to pick it up just
now see if I can throw it in the hamper
yet it smells still wet oh the neck was
still wet I was like it's six [__]
hours later
but it's funny I went down there today
and Tuesdays and Thursdays is a very
small class compared to their night
classes but there's one guy
that welcome to class dressed with his
gear already
no warm-up does not never never been
there at 12 30.
go sits down his feet are always dirty
sits down like Kung Fu
doesn't do hip doesn't do any of the
warm-up
sits there watches the technique
does it five times on each side gets up
bows and walks on huh that's all he does
he just wants to do a couple drills
that's it and he works as a security
where are you training that what part
down the blocks it's called dmac there
right around the corner I'll bounce like
I'll go to vmac uh but vmac doesn't have
all the classes and I I can't do
Wednesday nights I can't do Monday
nights I'm doing this so Monday days
I'll go to Higgins I'll shoot down the
Beverly Hills and I go to Higgins I went
there for the whole month of August a
little bit of July so now when this gets
better I'll go to Higgins at 11. it's 11
to 12 15 real quick and where's he in
the Beverly Hills Behind The Tuxedo shot
Higgin used to have a place in like
Redondo right no no no that was the
other brother
that was hodger who's got the place by
the ice house that we always John John
yeah I think
Carlos is in Dallas and John Jacques is
in tarzania and John Jacques is
apparently opening up a place in Austin
too with Todd White yes
somebody's opening up something yeah
because Todd White uh was uh he's one of
John Jack's black belts he's the artist
he used to work for Nickelodeon now he
does this uh amazing cocktail style like
1930s and 50s almost cartoonish really
cool stuff and he's super popular like
you can't turn out hard enough like
everybody wants to buy Todd whites I
went to a friend's house and she had a
Todd White thing on the wall like years
ago I was like this is crazy this is my
friend Todd's this is nuts she's making
bank right now like just kill him like
his average pick because somebody was
telling me the whole thing it's
ridiculous ball and out of control how
hard it is it's amazing well that's that
that art thing is a weird world like
once you become like a guy that
everybody wants to have a piece I want a
Joe Original Joe Diaz and you know
becomes like a thing that these art
people I was talking to a friend who
explained it to me and he was saying
that they manufacture it what they'll do
is they'll they'll get an artist and
then they they take a bunch of people
that they already have connections with
like really big people that buy fifty
thousand dollar paintings like nutty and
they buy them as Investments or because
they like art they buy them as
Investments they buy them because it's a
hobby it's a thing for them it's like
you know those crazy wine people those
people that are like that with art
they're crazy art people they're just by
Art and the gallery will contact them
and say listen there's a guy who's
coming up he is phenomenal and uh just I
want to gift you a piece because uh when
you're such a loyal customer and I'm
gonna gift you a 25 000 painting you
know because for a guy who's buying
millions of dollars worth of art because
a lot of these guys actually do buy
millions of dollars worth of art from a
particular gallery
gifting a guy at 25 000 piece is just an
investment but it's not really a 25
000. it's a 25 000 piece because they
say it's twenty five thousand dollar
piece so you gift four or five guys
these these big high roller Guys these
pieces now they're in the art community
well who's that that's an original Joe
Diaz yeah the gallery gave it to me it's
a 25 000 piece the guy's incredible wow
yeah he's having an there's gonna be a a
gallery show in October so then they put
on the gallery show in October the
prices have already been established and
then you see 35 000 nobody flinches and
they just start buying them like
hotcakes why because these big shots
already have the twenty five thousand
dollar pieces so they create this
bizarre bubble this bizarre market and
they do it by giving these like really
big high rollers expensive pieces it's
really fascinating it really is yeah
smart I mean they just look you know
what it is it's like it's a hustle they
figure out how to get in with these
people they figure out how to just how
to make it like
I was hearing about um there's certain
handbags that that really rich broads
are really into these certain bags I
don't remember the name of it but you
have to have a relationship with the
people that sell the bags in order to
even buy a bag like you can't just go in
off the street you have to have already
been a client so like you have to buy a
bag to get a bag so it becomes exclusive
so because it's exclusive they're
selling these bags for like fifty
thousand dollars and I'm like how the
[__] is someone paying fifty thousand
dollars for a purse it's a bag it's not
a Ferrari you can't drive it it's not
there's nothing there's no crazy
engineering involved in this it's not
like a watch that some guy made by hand
and he's got [__] giant goggles on it
takes six years to make a what no
because they've engineered this
exclusivity they've arranged it and they
just they work that market that market
of people with Incredible wealth because
especially where we are we don't even
realize it you know you grew up in a in
a place where it was like blue collar
and you know nobody was
multi-multi-millionaire but there's
places like
Brentwood or you know Bel Air where you
might have
a hundred people in a mile radius that
have a hundred million dollars like
that's not uncommon I mean there's
insane money in certain areas where
you're looking at these homes there's a
25 million dollar home that's a 30
million dollar estate this house is
going for 50 million I mean there's a
lot of that in this area and all they
have to do is tap into those folks
because they have insane disposable
income and what's expensive to you or I
it's not expensive to them it's nothing
twenty five thousand dollars for a
painting ain't [__] for them so they
figure out a way to weasel into that
world and then it becomes about that
world and it becomes about that
exclusivity you know this is an original
Joe Diaz look at that on the wall very
nice where'd you get it well you know
the gallery you know they've got a show
coming up I love this use of color and
they just trying to find ways to spend
their [__] money I mean they might
have a house in Costa Rica they got a
[__] house in Canada you know what I
mean like there's a lot of those people
in La that are just stupid rich
I heard that there's like a social
network now they have to pay like 10
grand to get into is that have you heard
about that no what's it called I'm
trying to find it right now
here we go social network that cost nine
thousand to join [__] idiots
Facebook is free stupid okay what are
you gonna get out of this social network
are they gonna blow you it's called
Metropolitan
Metropolitan it's six thousand to join
and then an additional 3 000 that renews
annually to keep to continue access oh
my God is anybody joining you have to be
21 let's see if it says uh they're not
sharing how many members of course
they're not there's two people in it oh
my God you have to be a real [__]
I can't imagine what if a pen breaks in
a 50 000 bag what if a nail polish thing
spills what if your dog pisses on oh my
God that's amazing I went to the park uh
I go to the park every [__] day but
the other day I went to the park and I
heard women talking
and they were talking about daycare
prices
in the area that they went shopping and
they go but what about that one in Van
Nuys and she goes oh my God I looked at
the web page and it was just I thought I
was dizzy I was on the swing and they
were on you know my baby was on the
swing and I was putting it so I could
hear them talking on the swing
and they were talking about how you have
to get on a list
to get your kid into this [__]
daycare
like you have to know somebody and then
they have to get you on the list
and it's exclusive in Van Nuys
I'm going like how did they make it
exclusive like what do the kids do
that's different is there a security
guard do they [__] fish you know give
them a chef right I mean are they
gluten-free meals I mean you know I
think I want my kid to get a little
[__] dirty I mean but they were
talking I heard them talking about like
percentages like let's say every other
daycare around is 200 a week this place
around like 1200 a week
like something just [__] ridiculous
something just ridiculous in Van Nuys
you know and it's the same thing how
they just make it exclusive it's
exclusive you have to get on the [__]
list a list for what so my kid could
play with [__] blocks
maybe it's just they just have a great
setup I mean maybe it's just like they
have a setup could it be 1200 a week
sounds insane that's something like with
comparison to what a regular daycare is
this is how much more it was wow and
they had like just you have to get on
it's six months and if your child's not
potty trained and I went home and I'm
thinking about I asked my wife and she
goes oh yeah they got them all over like
that that you the one by the house by
Marie Etc yeah that's a Christian Church
that have to waiting list of Jewish
people
because the daycare is just that good
what about pet hotels where they give
them like TVs and beds have you heard
about that yeah they put it like Animal
Planet on all day
Animal Planet all day yeah it's it's you
know Hey listen man it's whatever the
[__] you pay for whatever you believe
man
you know uh it's just [__] amazing
it's 25 000 for a picture or whatever
[__] artist and you sit there and
I've been to those things my buddy in
New York is like a great framer
his shop is in the Lower East Side and
whenever I go back easy gives me a hug
and he kisses me on both cheeks I mean
it's not his fault
but there's a lot of really good shows
and I think I don't think audio is the
future of entertainment I think it has a
future as a future but it's not the
future because there's always going to
be people that want to see things oh I'm
I'm not saying videos going away
obviously video is great but when when
the name of the game is advertisers and
advertising money that's like the end
goal for all of this
if you're losing people
for eight hours a day like I I think
what's great about these podcasts is the
people like middle class and are really
listening to it there are higher level
people doing it but if you can't listen
during the day you're probably a little
bit out of the loop podcast wise you
would think
so if you can't watch a video during the
day you you don't have all those ads I I
just think there's going to be a lot
more of that scripted podcasts Reality
Part I think there's going to be
everything because you have so much more
access yeah you have a lot of
possibilities how many people do you
think are really listening throughout
the day I that's all I did when I came
here that's how I found Joey through
your pocket I was listening all day at
my job right but isn't that unusual to
have a job that allows you to do that
how usual is that when you go on a plane
there's people watching a movie or
something with earphones on okay in
today's market people have an assignment
or have they have the type of report
they have you on they're not watching
you on YouTube but they're listening to
you they're listening to Bill Burr
listen to NPR
they're listening to The Comedy
essential podcast they're listening they
have 40 [__] hours to kill on that
[__] computer gaining hemorrhoids by
the day you know what I'm saying they
listen to two podcasts they get up they
go for a walk they smoke a cigarette
they drink a cup of coffee they come
back yeah they do a little work to
listen to another podcast
you know if you're a night security guy
you work [__] uh
you know all those hours at night you're
lonely in a car sitting there that's
when you listen so if we reach an hour
and a half a piece two hours you got a
lot of time at night to listen to
podcasts we're the kings of the third
crew Joe Rogan yeah right we are the
kings of the third group people that
work midnight to eight whether they're
in Australia China New Jersey California
that's who listens to this while they're
stalking [__] trucks uh you know
[__] product at a supermarket even
with a supermarket at two in the morning
and the guys are stocking they got
earphones on with the black gloves and
they're putting ice cream in the cases
they listen to everything
the Jim Norton's podcast listen to Opie
and Jimmy you know whatever [__] Jimmy
and whatever they listen to the dude
that used to be on there it's amazing
how much of a catalog they have to
choose from the first guy who ever
recognized me was a sign Spinner by my
by my job I was walking across the
street it was spinning he went to the
ice house a couple times I think he was
gonna try to be a comic that's funny
yeah ice spinner would be the perfect
guy that's hilarious this has gone to
places where it's you know you look at
your map at the end of the month and you
see where the people are listening to
this across the world wow and you go
what the [__]
you know like when Ari said he went to
China
he said 200 people showed up and they
all listened to the podcast they're
working for somebody over their apple
they work for problems yeah over there
what happens Foxconn that's over in
China right yeah that's where they make
the phones
since we were 15 in in summer school so
I play his game I go over there when I
was broken 84 I [__] made deliveries
from frames and pictures and [__] and
you know every night they go to these
things I've been with them where they go
and they sit they look in front of a
picture and they make believe they drink
wine these people don't give you sodas
they give you you know Sushi it's a
social thing it's a social thing it's a
it's a big social thing to be an art
collector because it shows that you have
a certain amount of taste you know like
if you if you're into obscure art that's
a Jackson Pollock mmm amazing amazing I
love what he's doing here is his concept
is incredible it's just I didn't know
there were any current artists getting
that much money oh I thought it was all
older people no you just have to be in
that circuit you just have to be in the
uh I was over uh Bob gersh's house Bob
Gersh is the [__] guy owns Gersh he's
the guy that I had to get on the phone
with to they were trying to get me to
apologize I've been seeing him and him
in the wig and uh
I'm out over his house in Aspirin it's a
long [__] time ago and uh he's got
this thing on his wall and it's like a
bunch of pieces of paper like it looks
like tissue paper glued onto other paper
and like a lot of paint and uh I look at
it I go I go this is uh is this
something is his kid made
and someone goes no that's a blah blah
I go what's that he goes that's worth
thirty thousand dollars I go what the
[__] are you saying I mean it wasn't
even big it was it was like as big as
that Longest Yard uh frame poster you
have up there that thing you know I mean
it wasn't like an enormous piece that
took [__] 50 years to make you know
no it's like a normal sized painting it
was like a bunch of [__] tissue glued
to a thing and some scribble it was
abstract Modern Art you know that's what
they call it abstract art dog [__]
nonsense unless it was your kid you know
if your kid made it it would be cute it
made sense to me I thought it was his
kid
it's like what the [__] is this this is
thirty thousand dollars it's like when
they throw that [__] like the like
the count of friends living down in La
he would throw the yard yeah and he
would light him on fire right yes [__]
to Live and Die in L.A that
[__] movie was on the other
morning at six in the morning I put on
KTLA news and I go let me see what else
is on I [__] put that's why I
remembered I put that part on it starts
with him burning a picture
he burnt the [__] pictures in the
beginning and at the end you know
there's those [__] guys that do the
art burned the picture because yeah it
just meant that my closure you know I
sit back going you gotta get your [__]
together guy it's [__] all over for
you you know it's the hard world is
filled with a lot of pretentiousness
they just uh just art itself calling
yourself an artist being an artist
wearing a scarf when they call
themselves an artist yeah that's where
my
fan and they justify by going you know
you're an artist
and I'm sitting but there are artists
what there are artists but these really
pretentious artists they [__] up the
whole concept of being an artist you
know like look Quentin Tarantino is a
[__] artist okay that's a guy who
creates badass [__] movies he's
it's an art to him you know what I mean
like
you know fill in the blank
Richard Pryor was an artist you know he
was a real artist he created art on that
stage
but some [__] they they say you
know I'm an artist and you just go
you just want to throw up on them yeah
it ruins the word
it real it ruins the term I mean how we
are the star yeah we're very finicky
what the [__] are you talking about I'm
an artist I just I can't be tied down
I'm I'm a free spirit you don't consider
yourself an artist Joey oh yeah every
morning when I wake up I'm gonna go see
August and show how well you are an
artist but you're a comic in the comic
supersedes everything else being a comic
is you know it's a different I mean it
is without a doubt an art form but it's
being a comic is the most important
aspect of the art form and that
eliminates any possible pretension
there's no you can't be pretentious to
be a [__] comic you're a [__] joke
Slinger you know that's what we do
you know just listen I could never I got
invited to this wedding I think I told
you I got invited to this wedding
usually I won't [__] go to a wedding
but it was in town and I don't go and
it'd be a nice date night for the wife
and we get to the wedding and the people
like oh my God we're so happy you made
it we put you in the celebrity table
and I'm like I'm not what and I go I'm
not sitting on no celebrity tape when I
walked all the way to the back and I
said that you know me dog celebrity who
else was at the celebrity table [__]
Gwen Stefani and a [__] husband and
uh the black dude from Rocky
Apollo Creed Apollo Creed and Carl
Weathers call weathers and you know just
a bunch of other people walking yeah
level celebrities yeah like just you
know Gwen Stefani is pretty big yeah
this is before she got pregnant like
this is this is about two years I'm
gonna be here she's still she was huge
was she here yeah you know Black Eyed
Peas right no no no no no that's first
oh no doubt yeah
but uh no it was just really weird that
that word right there no I sat in the
back table
you know man every time I like I hear
[__] like that like somebody comes
action like today I was washing the car
and somebody came in and said something
about oh I saw you on this or something
and I want to say I wish you would have
saw me when I robbed that [__] I
really don't know I wish I wish you
would have saw me
when I robbed the [__] uh
the the change thing for blankets from a
Carvel one day because I was sure four
bucks for a [__] 20 sack of weed you
know what I'm saying like I went into a
Carvel because I knew they always had
like fives and [__] so I bought like the
baseball cup with the ice cream in it to
give you like the Kansas City Royals you
get pissed off and I stole the [__]
can with the goods you know and that's
what I think about whenever somebody
says ah wow you role you had in the
movie and I feel like saying God you
even have a [__] idea like what are
you getting but why why is it bad that
they like you for a role in a movie like
what is it that you you want to like
redefine yourself no it's nothing about
redefining myself it's just about
um you know we were talking about my
uncle taking me to this game I tried to
Rob him 25 years ago at gunpoint and
whatever we don't talk about that like
Harvey wanted me to tell the story on
the story tell this thing and I said Ari
if you don't know my uncle he don't talk
about it but he very like I apologized
him on the podcast and he wouldn't even
he don't go there bro he's never told me
he loved me I tell him all the time I
love you Theo all right
my uncle does not [__] around do you
know about that place yeah yeah but how
many people actually jumped enough that
they made Nets it wasn't just one guy
when you when you put the Nets up I'm
building the cell phone makes you do
this they live there they live there
they work there they have dorms they
stay in the dorms they work all day it's
scary I mean it's It's A Step Above
being a slave and people tell you it's a
lot better than
um what they used to have because they
didn't have any opportunity and this is
just how industry works the way people
describe it they're trying to justify it
they say this is just how industry Works
Industry works you come into an
incredibly deeply impoverished area you
provide them with a way out like
something or a better way and so that
better way of working 16 hours a day
people could argue yeah they're working
16 a day for a dollar a day yeah or
whatever the wage they get which is
substantially lower than whatever they
make I might be exaggerating you could
probably Google it like how much does a
Foxconn employee get per hour
but they'd say that that's how they're
able to make these phones because they
can make them in these factories where
the people don't get paid as much but
there's a bunch of people that jump off
the roof like they have to put fences
nets all around the roof they have Nets
to catch people like it's bananas and
when they talk about it you know what
they say they say there's so many
employees at work there's like a half
million employees and the suicides are
directly proportional to how many if
that was like a population of a city
that makes sense that that amount of
people always kill themselves
but they don't do it at work
and they live there
how many is it it's uh the only local I
found was a little old but it was it was
like 12 a day you're gonna get like 400
a month wow
that's dark
there was some dude last night on 60
Minutes
pretty interesting there was two dudes
the guy who involved invented the Greek
yogurt yeah he was he needed seven
hundred thousand dollars and they saw a
Factory open up in New York and
he went to these people and he borrowed
the money he bought the what's the hot
Greek yogurt now I don't know
and he had to buy a plant in Twin Falls
Idaho
and he hide what he hires is refugees
he gives them jobs and people got pissed
off at him
and they call this guy donated 10 of his
Factory to his employees like they get
10 of the earnings every month from the
company they break it up almost like
like company sharing and all this [__]
it was pretty interesting that story was
interesting and there was another one
about a guy
who's saying that these phones are
programmed to program you
huh
watch this I was too deep for [__]
Uncle Joey how to turn this guy's saying
that the industry is pro they're
programming you
through computers and through the phone
his explanation you got to hear it when
you get a minute it was on last night
can you find out how much an iPhone
would cost if they made it in the United
States
I can Google it yeah Google that just
out of curiosity so how much would an
iPhone cost
there now well the what they cost now I
think four dollars a day they get paid I
think a new iPhone if you buy it in
America is like a thousand dollars
somewhere in that range no yeah but you
know the cell phone company subsidizes
it retail it's a thousand you get it for
200 because Sprint wants you to they
well they subsidize it or you they um
not subsidize it what's the word I'm
looking for they um they make like a
lease and they put it over the term of
the contract so they spread out the
amount of money that you're getting paid
or that you're paying for the phone so
if you're going to pay 600 bucks for the
phone they spread it out over three
years so you have a three-year contract
so like you can get it for like 200 off
and so it looks great it looks great but
it's just factored into your monthly
bill right and then you have them for
like three years I tried to pay the
phone they were like no they gave me a
good time yeah they don't want to do
that they don't want to do that they
don't want to do that it's probably more
valuable to them and then also you can't
leave I guess if you can leave if you
have like a phone that is uh what's the
word without a
no no I don't think it's that I think
it's unlocked jailbroken is when you uh
you get into it and you could [__] with
it right yeah yeah
so um it says that
if ever if all the components were made
in the US it would push the cost up to
600 which they think would retail it for
two thousand I'll see like a thousand
bucks more wow
hmm we gotta pay what a lot more in
[__] wages yeah more than twelve
dollars a day more like [__] 200 a
day yeah probably more than that right
what's a union wage for a factory worker
I wonder in America
let's go
you know and then people say well they
the cost of living is less over there
like okay but so is the standard of
living you know I don't know man I'm not
I'm no perfect person I don't and where
is this where they make these phones
China a certain city in China like a
real [__] I don't know I don't know
enough about it I probably should know
more but it's one of the dark things
about
um the cell phone industry I think they
said the new one they're going to make
somewhere else
why did I read did I read that somewhere
that they're gonna make the news they
change suppliers of something recently I
don't know let's see is it Canada did I
read the new iPhone will be made in
Canada did I read that or am I making
[__] up I could Google that next it says
the average assembly line worker makes
about 13 bucks an hour wow
that's not a lot
I thought it'd be a lot more for a
warehouse worker yeah like 16 18. isn't
it crazy that if you paid them that just
paying them that the cell phone would
cost another thousand bucks he told me
ran out yesterday he goes because I
thought I couldn't go to the game and
when I went he goes you called my
daughter and told her to take me to the
game that wasn't gonna [__] work
he was the only person I wanted to go to
the game with was you not even my son
today I like going to the game with you
could I take him once a year he's 76
he's my mother's brother you know but
yes down the way back I wish your mother
would grow up to see what you became
she goes at the funeral you were a lost
kid but when you came here every time I
looked at your eyes I saw the Charles
Manson that's exactly something to me so
that's what Nancy because I thought
about John muscle
he goes you were either gonna kill
somebody
he was telling me bro he that's what he
you know he called me out nobody had
ever called me out until I was 21 years
old you know what I'm saying right after
my mother died he might be so sensitive
don't say nothing to him he might snap
my uncle said I don't give a [__] if
your mother died that was five years ago
put it behind you it's over this ain't a
free world [__] I ain't giving you a
[__] dime but when he said that to me
last night that you know it really hit
home he goes you got to kill his eyes
you're gonna kill somebody you're gonna
kill me that [__] night you would
kill me
well we became friends you were
definitely a different guy in the late
90s
but you reminded me of everybody that I
knew from the pool hall like I I love
being around you because you were like
what I hated most when I first came to
La was that when I was in New York
and when I was in Boston I was
surrounded by uh you know East Coast
people that were either Comics or they
were martial artists or they were pool
players it was like there was a there
was a a grit to them it was a fun there
was a I could talk to them you know it
was there was real conversations to be
had and then come out here everybody was
like preparing for like we were
downstairs those people with their
scripts they're preparing and they're
sitting there in them and I'm seeing
them going over their lines going over
the thing I'm like this is hell this is
hell like this preparing for for a role
and being in the the whole the the whole
Hollywood scene like trying to get
people to like you and hire you for
things it's just this weird world it's a
weird world and here was this guy
hanging out at The Comedy Store there
was a total Hustler I mean you were a
total Hustler you know and we became
friends like immediately like we became
friends like right away I remember
bringing you around the [__] news
radio set and they're like who is this
guy this is [__] menacing guy in a
leather jacket that keeps eating all the
shrimp
happy birthday
and you know for me it was even The
Comedy Store that we loved was very
goofy oh it's goofiest Lee saw it a
couple of weeks ago I've been taking Lee
with me and I'm like oh you want to come
down you know he's gonna go home after
the parking they're gonna come to the
store and it was great the first three
or four times that he sat there when you
know he I got a tag for you you know
that was the worst it was the worst
thing I saw Tony I had to call him and
apologize the next day Tony Hinchcliffe
when he was with you in Sacramento or
something I had to call him and
apologize why because I had to get the
[__] out of that and Tony came up to me
I'm like Tony I love you I see it and I
I I was telling you that someone was
telling you they had a tag for you
like hold on they're like listen man I
heard that joke and we got to give you
this tag you should say
I don't even know and at least I mean at
least like that was [__] weird and
then the next night we went down again
and that's what the guys were saying we
have this idea for a TV show oh oh my
God and you're like
I just get on stage I just you know
you're walking to your car you're not
even thinking about a TV show yeah
you're thinking about how you should
have said the instead of cat you know
just dumb [__] of course can we have a
word and he was right there we had this
idea for you for a TV show not even how
are you right what have you been up to
and he looked at me we were Eyes [__]
which really kills you when you're at
the comedies when somebody's trying to
sell you something
and then Tony Hinchcliffe came
and I saw Tony I'm like I can't even you
know I gotta get out of here like my
head was about to blow up the highness
the set the people trying to sell me a
TV show and the people that are trying
to sell you things at the comic store
most likely they never sold [__] before
they just have an idea and they think
they're going to come to you and that's
how they're going to do a TV show right
and it was just the idea we looked at
each other like are they [__] I mean it
was just so I understand that like at
The Comedy Store there's always that one
person that you find warmth in and I
found that with you because
everybody had to come everybody at that
time
was looking to get on a show at a quick
comedy
there was a big of that people would get
on a TV show and that was it yeah and it
would happen like
four or five times and here's this guy
that tapes a great show and after the 10
hour 12 hour shoot still comes and does
his 15 set in the original room at 12
o'clock I couldn't figure it out most
people would just go home and go [__]
stand up that's below me you know [__]
stands I don't know write a joke you
know and it's really weird the people
that have stuck it up and will always be
stand-ups like I always give those guys
respect don't come back to it after the
show got canceled and do stand there
yeah while your show is on you tell your
agents hey those weeks that you don't
have me up at Warner Brothers
I want to be out the whole [__]
summer I want to do this I oh no well
the the show doesn't want you to curse
on stage say any fact jokes on stage
that's what they did to Tim Allen no
[__] you know so Saget too yeah no [__]
so you have to and here I'm watching
this guy that's going against everybody
else
he's going against what everybody else
believes everybody wants to you used to
call it someone means to the end and to
the means it means a means to an end
that's it I that in my life that's not
how I felt to me if I got on a show that
just helped me that'll help me get up
there and it gets easier now when I go
to a club in Iowa my dream was to get in
the car and pull a Mitch Hedberg and go
to all these clubs just drive across
country one time you know be on a TV
show do the 26 episodes but once that
shit's over we're getting your car and
go bon voyage I'm on here and just go
across the country and you see a funny
bone jump in there you see a comedy
catch jump in there yeah you see a
comedy Saloon jump in there you see a
pizza place with an open mic and you're
in Minneapolis [__] jump in there you
do that for six or seven weeks as a
stand-up comic and people go well I just
thought you were on TV I didn't know you
were this [__] funny or this is what
this is what I do I didn't give a [__] I
didn't I didn't
when I was growing up and I was watching
Charles Bronson I love Charles Bronson I
love when he killed somebody I loved all
that [__] with the cheer me foolney with
the fly and and then but I never thought
I was gonna do that I thought that I
would always be an extra if they ever
used me I thought that they were going
to come to The Comedy Store and say hey
you you want to be in my movie you know
I've watched Hollywood nights you ever
see Hollywood Nights with Tony danz and
Michelle Pfeiffer you see all the all
the people around them are comics in The
Comedy Store uh arlis
TK Carter is the black guy that's doing
the fraternity run the dude who had the
show Once on uh married men Mike binder
he's the [__] uh the kid who has the
mind of a married man Mind of a married
man he's the [__] Hollywood
Knights is a a famous place is closing
down on Hollywood Boulevard but these uh
Hall of these Hollywood Nights they they
have to I I didn't forget it's just but
the scenes when they take these black
guys and they put sheets on them they
make them walk through a white man I
mean it was just crazy and the people
pissing the punch but if you look at all
the comment in that movie they just went
into the store and picked up a bunch of
[__] one night and put them in
there the same thing with Gabe Kaplan
who we would grew up with the same thing
with Jimmy Walker you know suppose they
cut the deal to uh good time and they're
back in one of the boots there Freddie
Prinz that's what we came from but you
always remain the stand up you always
that was your roots when I came here
they I got here and they said all right
you gotta go for an audition from ypd
boo I didn't go to an acting I didn't
know nothing about that I knew nothing
about that dog I knew nothing about
commercials I thought they shot
commercials and [__] mods I know the
[__] they shot commercial when I came
here seriously I'm not lying [__]
commercials I came in they go you your
face is great for commercial okay yeah I
don't know I know nothing I didn't even
know I never even thought about shooting
[__] commercials I got a friend of
mine was analyzed that was that your uh
your first big movie
NYPD Blue didn't get it and as I was
walking by a door a lady pops on she
goes you're here for your audition I
guess so give me a sheet of paper I read
it and boom I booked three weeks of five
grand I never saw nothing like that in
my life wow I snorted every penny today
and then I robbed the [__] roller
skates I robbed a different pair of
roller skates every [__] day
all right everything I went and I
returned them at Five Guys what is that
the five sports sports guys I think I'm
[__] kidding you I would get to my
room they'd be a size 13. I'd wear them
I put them back in the box and clip them
the lady would come with wardrobe
anybody see the roller skates
no I put them in Wonder okay
every day for three weeks every day come
back again it's like 13 and I started
giving me size 12. we don't know what
happened on the third thing me neither
what the [__] what the [__] going on
then they went on 12 they went down at
11. I was put in 11. oh I was going I
was coming home with Band-Aids but I
didn't give a [__] they're 140 a pop
plus tax when I return them and they
were same every day the same sporting
good how you doing what what happened
your grandma gave me how did you know
all right what do you want cash and
check let me get some cash though I can
stop and get gas
by the time I quit by the time I stopped
shooting I was down for like a size
eight and a half
but you know I think if you look at the
who they were they were amazing I mean
their finished product like what they're
able to put together was [__] amazing
and whether it came out of those four
guys heads or those four guys heads and
some other people's heads too it's the
the effort the culminative effort of
those artists to put all that music
together and make these insane songs the
real problem is somebody didn't get
credit for it that's the real problem
the real problem is somebody didn't get
paid you know and they definitely used
it for their end product so if you
looked at it like say if you had a car
you're putting together a car and uh
there's a bunch of different components
there's a transmission there's the
engine but they want to put your
transmission in you know but they don't
want to pay you for your designs they
just copy it and put it in there and
then you find out hey but this is all my
engineering I I did all this research
and development I should just copied it
exactly they should they're supposed to
say yeah you're right here's some money
and then the question would be well how
much money do they deserve that's the
problem because they probably deserve a
problem that's many times they played in
concert it's kind of oh it's kind of
like a forensic [__] people in there
it would be insane so it wouldn't just
be a matter of a little bit of money
it'd be a matter of economy changing
money so it's going to be hard to get
someone to sign off on it and for
probably I mean I don't understand too
much about how the legal system works
but I would imagine that the lawyers
that represent Led Zeppelin must be out
of this [__] world yeah no that big
time that's the that's that's the record
label they sell their soul to say yeah
you would be you would be betting
against the most ruthless Savages in the
history
people
to that the music industry did you ever
read that Court uh love uh article that
she wrote where she explained she broke
down the music industry no she broke
down what everybody gets paid it's
really well written it's so well written
that they uh thought they accused
somebody else of writing it and she was
a she got a ghost writer that's how well
written it is
because it goes into detail about how
artists get [__] and how musicians get
[__] and where all the music goes or
the where the money rather for the music
goes and how little of it actually makes
it down to the artist and this is back
when they were selling records now it's
it's weird because right now the touring
is where I guess the artists make their
money and Joe you said uh that you don't
think someone a court would find them I
think if they got the right jury like a
younger a younger jury who didn't have
as much attachment to Led Zeppelin I
think they might see it from that point
of view like they I think it's well
known now that artists don't make that
much money from their music anymore so I
think like some people might I mean they
tried they said they stole this in 1970.
that was the problem right there that it
was 47 [__] years ago 47 years of
owing them millions and millions of
dollars like you were talking for that
song you might be talking like 500
million dollars or something crazy it
might be more than that that might be
like conservative
like you're you're talking about the the
if if not the biggest super band one of
the biggest super bands of all time all
the time the toured everywhere and you
gotta remember 1973 in this country
we did two billion dollars in music
sales I saw that on the 70s it was the
biggest year tour everybody was on the
road
everybody from Earth Wind and Fire The
Temptations Led Zeppelin the stones Pink
Floyd everybody was on the road in those
days Aerosmith this was a [__]
Masterpiece of people Ted Nugent did you
ever see Searching for Sugar Man
no the one that won the Oscar about the
musician yeah Elvis or something like
that well no you know this he no he um
which was huge in South Africa and he
never knew it he was a huge star and
there's all these legends about what
happened to him and how he died and you
know but he his and his music is good
man it's good it's just for whatever
reason it didn't hit in the 1970s when
he released it and so this guy became
like a laborer and he worked
construction and he raised a family and
he stuck around but he stepped he still
kept like practicing his music and then
one day someone found him and they
couldn't even believe it was him they
thought that he was dead and someone
found him and told him hey man you
you've been huge in South Africa forever
huge he was like what and he went over
to South Africa like after he'd been
poor for like 30 years or something like
that you know like literally living in a
place where he's got like a wood stove
and he's burning fire in the wood stove
burning logs in there stay warm they
show him doing this he goes over South
African sells out arenas
they can't even believe it when they see
him they can't believe it he starts
singing songs they know the words they
sing along with him he's coming back
from the dead it's insane he's it's more
than he's coming back from the dead it's
like this guy was a huge Superstar
and
he was impoverished he was like he was
almost like living a fake life for 30
years they didn't even know
how do they become youth in South Africa
they play this music on the radar so one
guy found it could be could be one guy
found it sometimes that [__] happens do
they have an album out yeah yeah a
couple he made no money on them no they
didn't give him a [__] dime they
apparently made he made one that he had
a chance to make the second one and he
really you know they they gave it a big
push but it just didn't catch
and they don't know why you know maybe
it was what the album looked like you
know maybe it was uh people just didn't
give it a chance but it was good he's a
good musician and after that second
album he quit but that music made its
way to South Africa it made me cry
it really did I just like it was I
forgot all about it somebody told me to
watch and I have forgotten all about it
now I'll watch it dude I was getting
tears I was tearing up because I was
watching and I was like this is this is
a this story is amazing because the
stories about this guy that just became
this weird sort of humble guy who's
really philosophical and kind of Zen
about life and he gave all the money
away all the money he made tauren after
it became huge in South Africa I gave it
away went back to living just like how
he was living before
at least that's what they tell you
that's the legend I hope not well you
know I don't know I mean maybe he was
happier that way maybe he just decided
that at his age I think he's in his 60s
at his his age all of a sudden becoming
this big star and going to South Africa
and flying across the world and making
money and not knowing why you're doing
it and you know and everybody says
you're supposed to do it he didn't like
it I think he just wanted a quiet more
peaceful life maybe still touring a
little bit but damn
I bought the album I bought uh whatever
he has out there whatever I could buy on
iTunes it's I think it's one it might be
two albums I think it's one I'll make
sure he's getting the [__] money yeah
okay I've been taking it from him for
the last 30 years these [__] now
iTunes comes along and gives you a 40-60
split I wonder what they would give him
in South Africa for all that all the
times they sold his records
listen man I heard something that John
Oates Daryl homeworks
in the end of 1990 they had sold 8
million records and they both had 50 in
their bank account
whoa where'd you hear that on uh Eddie
Trunk on mysterious radio that he's
going to release a book now
the music business is as filthy as it
gets I don't get it
we had Danny Brown I tried to have him
explain to me all this mixtape world and
how I don't get it
I don't get it I see it now I buy a an
album for 8.99 it sells a million
animals what's that 8.9 million
I think right yeah 899 million no no
8.99 8.99 oh but just say think of nine
dollars okay it sells a million nine
million nine million [__] dollars how
much is the hardest get they got like
two million I wonder the record label I
walked into the weed store today and
they were playing Billie Jean
the video that's the first time I saw
him when was the last time you saw
Billie Jean 15 [__] years ago I
started looking at it I thought about
the that's when the record label put up
a half a mil for a video yeah
I have a [__] milk you remember when
Madonna had that uh like a virgin
no no like prayer is that what it was
though she brought the Black Jesus yeah
people went [__] bananas you know all
of them then then Coke or somebody
signed Michael Jackson's hair went on
fire yes yes that's what started the
pain pill addiction because when they
when he died they realized that whole
thing was a wig
oh man he burnt his hair off the whole
time it had been awake he had that scars
in the back and the whole thing oh wow
they lit him on fire and burnt his hair
off that's why he sued Coca-Cola whoever
it was Pepsi Coca-Cola wow that makes
sense I mean if especially you consider
all the chemicals he used to have in his
hair you know at 84 yeah so that's hair
spray is super flammable that's what
started the pain that's when he started
telling people he was getting pain in
his neck he couldn't sleep at night so
that's how he was getting all his
medication and then he'd go to these
different parties and mingle and spread
the word and they tell him stop by
tomorrow we got a [__] bag of goodies
for you on the house wow and that's what
led to him you know [__] shooting
whatever the [__] he was shooting at the
end well he was taking tranquilizers at
the end they were they were using like
sedatives on them to make him go to
sleep so essentially they were they were
um putting him under sedation every
night
they were using anesthesia
there was they were just conking them
out like but I guess when you do that
you go out and [__] but you don't really
sleep like part of what you need is not
just to be unconscious you need to go
through those Cycles those Cycles in
your head and when you're under
anesthesia you're not going through
those Cycles
I'm not a doctor no no I get you it's
like getting the surgery it's like when
I got my nose surgery one minute you're
there and then you're gone you don't
remember [__] about what happened you
wake up you don't really know if you're
tired or if you slept or not it's kind
of a weird feeling it is weird you kind
of think about the lights you see the
lights and you can't remember what's
going on so I don't know how they can
today I know if you get [__]
done one time it's pretty [__] bad
for you if you get done like if you get
anesthesia people watch it people say
it's not good and that's what people
can't handle yeah that's what goes wrong
when they come out here and they've been
[__] killing in Iowa or whatever the
[__] they're from and they go in The
Comedy Store and they're sandwiched in
between Rogan and Nick the Pollo and
it's Post Time [__] it's Wednesday at
10 45 and you got the 11 o'clock spot I
need a sandwich and you you know you
know it's it's a [__] nightmare and
it's your skin and it's your your pride
if you hang out or whatever for a guy
like me I didn't give a [__] I knew it
was about percentages and I knew that
the more you got up there and you worked
a little bit at it the better you get
did you did you ever do stand up in New
York did you ever like no no
you're doing New York this weekend we're
doing Gotham that's a great Club Great
Club but you know the best place New
York I did New York in 94. what I did
was I go to New York comedy club I go to
stand up New York
the dude that was sick didn't like me at
comedy uh whatever yeah Lucian didn't
like it man and then there was these
other little holes that I would go to I
would drive a limo and in between
driving limos I would stop
and get on stage and I was terrible and
I knew I was terrible
but my options were I would go back and
do Coke and cry and look at stand-up
comedy by Judy Carter and look at the
comedy newspaper
you know that you should be just for
last I came out of San Francisco and I
would read the articles like I still
remember the best articles I read in
there were about Hicks and you know they
had different comedy scenes all over the
country it's very interesting to read
and at the end they had all the active
comedy clubs and it was Pages you know
Arizona Arkansas
uh you know uh whatever what started
with B with a can of California you know
and you looked at all igb's and all
these clubs and you had this dream that
someday I might get good enough and I
might be able to play at eight piece you
know and then uh what's her name to the
contest that the Comedy Works
and Wendy Wendy did a contest and the
winner got 500 bucks and a ticket to Los
Angeles to perform in for Mitzi Shore
at the world famous comedy store
the dude Matt Woods
Matt Woods and Matt Berry Matt Berry
sold shows Matt Woods was his buddy and
he would work with comics on Tuesday
night and take him to his apartment and
you wrote and then you go to the open
mic I was always doing the sports
betting thing I couldn't get to his
apartment
so he didn't really dig me so then I had
a contest I came in second but the first
place guy had Rob Seinfeld and all these
Comics said hey Rob Seinfeld so Joey
gets the
the redeem I got the 500 but I never had
one ticket so he stole some Seinfeld's
jokes to win the country to win the
contest
you know when I was raised with the
[__] old interview sheets remember
when you apply for a job in the 70s it
said five lines your name addressed and
there was a box and it said don't answer
the [__] questions unless there's a
check in that [__] box that my friend
thought I was at a sandwich place one
time and I go you need help man hire
someone he goes look at all these people
who applied already I can't hire none of
these dummies because they all [__]
wrote in here and it says don't so if
they can't get that right yeah I don't
want to do business with them and people
don't listen I don't want to do business
with them like if I tell you something
an hour and two hours later you call me
with something stupid I just don't meet
you from the phone like I'm I'm done
like I'm [__] done I can't deal with
so I wanted to make people [__]
listen again it's a great gift to have I
love to talk but I also love to [__]
listen the other day when you and
Dominic were talking 40 minutes and I
raised my [__] hand no did I raised
my [__] hand no I'm learning I didn't
have I I wasn't in the place to [__]
raise my hand i'm amongst people who
really know what the [__] they're
talking about that's a problem in
America today people want to chime in
when they don't know what the [__]
they're talking about you think I went
to Jujitsu because I like smelling
[__] and feet and you think I like
joking I definitely don't it's not in my
itinerary but you know what man I'm sick
and tired of listening to MMA [__]
analysts that never even tackled the
[__] tackle dummy how are you gonna
know what this guy is feeling in the
ring if you never got clocked in the
face do me a favor shut the [__] up
that's with any sports writer they they
sit there and they insult football
players when's the last time you played
football [__] all do you know what
they're doing out there now no you know
it happens with basketball it happens
with baseball there's always these
people that you look at them and they've
never done nothing in their [__] life
and they want to write about a sport
they don't know oh I was a fan of the
game no you were a fan but you never
played it do you know Annex started
taking Jiu Jitsu you have to from you
have to yeah me just [__] around with
you guys I have to do something I have
to describe a hip Escape I have to know
what it's like before I can sit there
and judge a guy right where the [__] am
I but that goes on a lot in today but
let me start up a Blog because you know
and talk bad about Michael's Biz being
not fighting whatever you thought what
the [__] did you do but you did a lot of
it is I'm just trying to get attention
and the way to get attention is to be
negative and I I've been very vocal
fighting against that I don't like
insulting writers that that [__] on MMA
in particular
because at any level it's not they're
not respecting what that thing is that
thing is an insanely difficult Endeavor
to be a fighter and to put your emotions
on the line and then for someone to
callously disregard that look you can
pump up the person who won and you could
criticize the technique of the person
who lost but they go way further than
that there's some of them that they they
make a person look like a buffoon I
don't like none of that [__] there's no
reason for that we learned a lot with
Ronda Rousey we learned a lot about
Society there's two things that taught
me a lot the last year when Ronda Rousey
got knocked out and when [__] Trump
won and then [__] mutt went to his
house for dinner to try to interview for
the job after he bad mouth him that
Christine no no not the fat [__]
when Rick Romney and then Trump won he
went to his house and you know why
people didn't say nothing about it
because people do it all the they're
just snakes they're disgusting well
we've become disgusting people you know
so that's why nobody ever said wait a
second that guy's a [__] mutt he'll
never get he should be banned like
United
you you talked about Trump I mean you
went out and blasted him not just sacred
speech yeah pre-write speech and now
you're going to his house to try to get
a job you should be shot and hung he
rehearsed that [__] yeah but Americans
didn't see it they just let it go that's
why Lee's right you know what we all see
this thing where United I don't [__]
United's always my third choice
United is my fourth choice
okay it's American I go to Delta I go to
JetBlue I try uh virgin but they don't
fly everywhere they go to Austin you got
to go to San Francisco first I ain't got
that type of time so the only time I
could use them is to go to [__] New
York that's the only use I got out of
Virginia they're great to New York
though but United I look at every once
in a while like
should I take the chance they want
someone to come through with like a
short flight it's an hour and a half you
can catch a night you don't really want
to go on Southwest but you know what
[__] you [__] you I don't like you
[__] anyway you can't wear your
yoga pants [__] I gotta help you guys
with the sound I know you gotta figure
this out yeah you need a uh you need a
whole board that takes this then um
but don't tell them compression don't
tell them because then they all become
sound designs
yeah we'll figure this out I love you I
love you too brother I love you thanks
for everything man thank you thanks for
this weekend too tremendous we got to
eat those wings that was great [__]
around none of these [__] West Coast
Wings with rents suck my dick
[Music]
relax
foreign
[Music]